[Music]
with chefs like me are gonna not only
know but they want to be part of the
action
what is very important about indoor
farming is that this opportunity to
really understand the possibilities that
we have in the years to come to get here
in the world
[Music]
so at bowery we build smart warehouse
scale indoor farms
we stack our crops from the floor to the
ceiling
under lights that mimic the spectrum of
the sun
so we can grow 365 days of the year
completely independent of weather and
seasonality
what we're really doing is not just
reinventing farming we're actually
reinventing the entire supply chain
we're locating our farms close to the
cities that we are actually serving this
means that we can deliver our product a
day or so after harvest versus weeks or
months of time the traditional
agricultural system
jose andres has been an investor and an
advisor and a friend of bowery for quite
some time
alexandra kitchen we are able to respond
in multiple events at once some because
the pandemics have some because a
political situation and this is the
situation inside ukraine right now
the coups like me that would fit the
world we are finding many of the
solutions to solve many of the problems
that we face in the simple thing of
producing food
i saw what was going on
and getting the opportunity to be part
of with a no brainer poverty as pushing
the wounder is how do we maximize
technology you see the
amazing team of scientists of
researchers
this is about producing but it's about
research and development that is
happening
we grow completely pesticide-free
produce so there's no herbicides no
fungicides no insecticides we're over a
hundred times more productive than a
square foot of traditional farmland and
we use only a tiny fraction of water
compared to traditional agriculture
what makes that all possible is a
combination of robotics and automation
that we design and develop on our own
as well as the bowery operating system
it allows us to control at a very micro
level
all of the conditions and the attributes
around our crops and to adjust variables
in real time and that kind of control
allows you to drive flavors and
attributes of crops that we've never
even experienced yet before
at bowery we've focused on leafy greens
and herbs as a start and we have the
technology we have the retail
partnerships we have the know-how to
begin to move into new crops
the strawberry is this incredible
representation of what we can do at
bowery
it's a fruit that's extraordinarily
seasonal one of the most pesticide
ridden fruits
these aren't issues that we face at
bowery and so we can focus on variety
and flavor and texture
this strawberry is quite awesome the
smell is unbelievable
it's a great strawberry if the
strawberries are as good as the ones i
taste today of course being my
restaurants totally
bringing the right technology the smart
technology to be able to produce faster
quicker better smarter less use of water
now doing strawberries that tells me
that the next crops will be even more
calorie-dense crops
at bowery we've been growing hundreds
and hundreds of variety of crops we're
thinking about agriculture for the
generations to come given the climate
crisis that we're dealing with today
more mechanisms to produce food in
sustainable way more chances we have to
solve many of the footages we face
not all of us have the luxury to go to a
farmers market we can bring that high
quality local fresh produce to consumers
everywhere in all types of retailers as
well
and we just recently announced that
we're building a farm in arlington texas
we're building a farm in atlanta georgia
as well and ultimately move from a
national based business to a
global-based business
i believe we need a very big ecosystem
to be doing doesn't mean that this
is going to be fighting against the
smaller farmers in america around the
world i think it's wrong for everybody
so what you see here is very much
the future in more ways than one
[Music]